okay so the first technique i want to
look at is
ikeo
we're looking at this picture here
and
a few of my thoughts so i heard some
stories of ikkyo working some bjj people
using the elbow to not like really to
immobilize people on the ground
but to manipulate the elbow to get into
a better position
and i guess it kind of makes sense the
technique but i haven't explored it that
much i haven't encountered functional
versions of it so my guess is
i'd say ikkyo
i put it somewhere in the middle
thinking that it may have that potential
to work but i'm not really sure and i
think i even heard you once saying
something good about ekio so so where
would you put that
one time i said something good about eco
yeah no i would actually put it maybe
even in the super category i'd put it in
the a category um but but not yeah but
not eco um as a form and so i think it's
important to distinguish the technique
itself from the form so forms are this
process i go through like show me cheek
or something but eq itself is elbow
control i mean that's the basic idea of
ikkyo and i think some people might see
it more as like um in japanese you call
it consetsuwaza right it's like joint
techniques or something i don't think of
it as a joint technique at all i think
of it as elbow control and the reason i
would put it so high is because if
you've ever been in any kind of
situation especially if you're talking
about
dangerous self-defense arm situations
controlling someone's elbow is
absolutely essential because when
someone's arms flailing around it's
really hard to get their wrists to grab
their wrist out of the air super super
hard to do that um and if you grab at
their shoulder it's easy to get a hold
of their shoulder but their shoulder
doesn't really give you any control over
the arm so elbow control is the nice
midsection between the the shoulder and
the wrist and it's usually pretty easy
to get and if i control someone's elbow
usually i keep them from stabbing me or
hitting me or doing anything else so
elbow control i think is super super
important and then eco as it starts to
become a form shows a way that we can
turn that elbow control into an
unbalancing technique that we could use
as a takedown or we could use it as a
projection
and then we could hold someone on the
ground with it and i've made uh videos
talking about the eco pin and there are
definitely a lot of weaknesses to the
eco pin um it's not super secure i would
take top mount over ikkyo pin any day in
a security situation but in a situation
where i didn't know if the other guy was
armed or not i would rather have ethio
because i could bail out of there
quicker than i can something like top
mount so so i think echo is highly
functional but in a gross sense and not
in a specific like here's how you take
them down and hold them to the ground i
don't think it's that functional in that
sense all right hey that that's awesome
and i had doubts if we'll get to any
super techniques
so that's
good i mean i use it constantly so like
when we do raw dory and stuff i use eco
non-stop nice and i i do think i saw
like you posted those great videos of
you
uh
working in your garage or or some other
area with your
with your students and people like still
exploring at your early days i think i
saw you maybe that's where i picked up
that you were using sometimes echo
naturally would come up
and and you'd say said that it's a
decent technique do you think i'm
remembering that right
no you're remembering right yeah yeah
i've got some live footage of it coming
off in live situations um and it does um
but to see it completely like a form is
kind of rare um and i think that's a lot
of the problems with the ikea techniques
is it's hard to not confuse them with
the form and it forms one really
specific situation you know so um the
technique of eq which is elbow control
super functional you need it like in a
self-defense situation it's you can't
live without it in lots of ways because
people's arms are just too dangerous
right so you know in boxing i can high
cover or something or low cover and
that's great if someone's just going to
hit me but if someone's coming in with a
knife i can't really hide cover the
knife goes right through there and gets
me anyways you know so um something that
gives me elbow control is real essential
awesome now i'm even more looking
forward to come and visit you and and
experience that
that's another day
uh okay so next one
nikkio
and my first thoughts
uh i know a bunch of people in brazilian
jiu-jitsu
pulling off nikki or or certain like uh
nico-esque type of technique i still
haven't got to that point although it's
high on my list
but
just that wrist manipulation i think
especially like not if not necessarily
if somebody's grabbing
because i i would for a moment i would
doubt okay if i would really secure the
hand strong enough so they wouldn't pull
out but there's that you know locked
version where you can kind of get that
person
still i have those questions how would i
get to that point
uh
is that does it really come up often
that that place like in jiu jitsu i
guess it makes sense because we're
grabbing so much each other we're using
the ghee and
doing g-game it's so
grip reliant that the nikki can come up
other than that i have some questions
but i think i definitely imagine that
nikkio is
potentially good technique
i guess i'd be between b and c but let's
say b
what about you
um i'd probably it really depends on how
you're using it so um you know if you're
talking about the kiawaza so ikkyo
through rokyo nico is definitely in
there um
those are principles and they can do a
bunch of stuff so if you're talking
about nico as a controlling technique
like i want to take someone down with it
or i want to hold someone still with it
it's okay i would maybe put it at a a d
um or an e you know like if that's where
you're looking at it now if you're
looking at it as a clearing technique
how to get someone's uh arm off of me i
would say it's pretty high right so
maybe a b or an a right so like nico can
really reach someone's arm off you if
they've got a good control on the side
now that's not you know taking them down
with it or making them cry uncle or tap
or anything like that it's just clearing
if we're talking about disarming i would
put it in the a or s category because
it's a super disarming technique so nico
and korigaisch to me and we'll probably
get to coda geisha in a minute are our
essential disarming techniques so if
you're going to take something out of
someone's hand you have to know those
two and so it really depends on how
you're looking at it and nico's hard so
it's always ikyo and a lot of other uh
in the kyowasa because they're
principles and so it's not like you know
if you're talking about like an armbar
and brazilian jiu jitsu like um you know
juju garuma like so the uh regular
armbar where you'd have their their arm
between your legs you know
so that's a functional technique but
locking someone's elbow out is a
principle and it's bigger right and so
you know you could say like well you
know what about the technique of locking
someone's uh elbow on my shoulder like
how useful is that well that itself is
not that useful but the principle of
locking an elbow is really useful right
and so that's the way i look at nico
because what nico does is it folds the
wrist down and it takes the wrist to the
side and so when it does that your grip
just gets so weak that it's hard to hold
on and so i bet you use nico all the
time when you're rolling it's just
you're not thinking of it because it's
not you know you're not making someone
tap with it you're just using it to get
someone's arm off of you and i bet a lot
of people use nikki all the time because
it when the hand gets put in that
position it's just so natural to happen
so nico as a principal is indispensable
but you know as a hold or like how we
see it a lot in the forums is is not
very useful you know it's pretty pretty
low i mean especially if you're
considering something like uh you know
like uh an american lock or a kimura or
something like those are so much more
useful as far as holding someone still
or jam damaging the joint nico's not as
good as those at that right so sorry
that wasn't a clear no no no we can
still clarify i really like how you're
distinguishing you know it's it's
a or b for this element it's your d for
that element so i guess to kind of find
the middle if we'd
qualify the technique for specifically
how useful
it could be
if we made it and kind of finding the at
the average usefulness of its potential
uh let's say what would be
the the middle
score that you choose for it
yeah i mean i think where you put it at
b is fine because um it to me it's
really low
for um a hold or a submission like
pretty low for that but very very high
for a clear or a disarm and so you know
averaging out it's probably in the b ish
category i would say got it
cool it's awesome
okay so next one we're looking at senkyo
uh
i know sankyo works as a back escape you
say my computer sorry oh did i first
i'll just repeat what i said like
okay so yeah thank you
i know it works as a back escape like
you know if somebody has you like in a
lock and you grab the arm and you start
twisting and they freak out and you
squeeze yourself out i tried that that
was great but that's a very specific
situation
uh i did lift up a couple of people by
by thank you i did catch a couple of
people even in standing i mean the the
part where i go under the
armpit that kind of is questionable
uh but
again this is for me it's still just
exploration but i can definitely see
like how the wrist can be twisted and
especially if the elbow's really locked
up high and you're able to get to that
position i think there's potential in
senko
i'm also maybe affected by your
positivity i didn't expect the
techniques to score so high
so i'm kind of naturally wanting to go
to
a b a but let's say
i put it on a w what about you
it's interesting to
watch kind of how you're um
you're assessing them because i think
you're assessing them um really from a
um a domination standpoint and and
that's the way a lot of people look at
martial arts is that you know martial
arts are about dominating and i tend to
look at martial arts that i'm interested
in as about survival right so i just
want to get the hell out of there most
of the time i don't want to sit and
prove who's the best i'm not interested
in that anymore you know um and so like
i see how to you um sankyo seems better
than nikyo because i think it is a
little bit better for controls and holds
and submissions it's a little more
useful than nico in that category but
it's also less useful to me
in in clearing and uh disarming
techniques now it is a decent disarming
technique and it is a decent clearing
technique but it's not nearly as
functional as nico is for that and so to
me it's a little lower than nico i think
nico's a little better you know so i
think really the kilwaza which are one
through six or depending on the aikido
style maybe one through five or one
through seven but um
uh they really do kind of go in a level
of importance in a lot of ways and so to
me i would put sankyo underneath nikyo
but if we're averaging out like you're
talking about i would say let's go for a
b because to me it is a better
controlling technique and a better
submission technique just not as good at
clearing and disarming right so if we're
averaging them out i'd probably stick it
around b um yeah b or c somewhere in
there all right uh again i really
i'm really enjoying the your thought
process and it's a great insight that is
that you just noticed
i guess i am in that stage i'm
interested in self defense and i always
think about self defense uh
but
my main focus is combat sports these
days i'm going to like a few kickboxing
classes per week some jiu-jitsu and and
i realized that this it's not
self-defense but at the same time just
that's that's what i do these days you
know that's my main focus and absolutely
nothing wrong with that right and i
think maybe that's one of the reasons
why my focus is more like okay how does
it work
in a fighting situation versus your it's
almost like the reflection of you know
i'm still just starting out in this
journey and and you've already been on
this journey for a long time and you
matured into that aspect of okay well
you know fighting combat sports yeah
it's fun but self-defense is actually
what really matters because that's life
preservation and and survival so so yeah
it's a it's quite fascinating to
to see see the difference of where uh
the focus is so yeah
i think that focus is important to talk
about too because um i've said to people
before you know if you're sub 25 um
you're interested in a different kind of
thing than over 25 uh uh years of age
and what i mean by that is you know if
you're younger you're thinking about
like how do i impress people how do i
impress girls how do i become stronger
how do i become more able those are your
main focuses and so that
like you know uh combat sports or i call
them sport martial arts are are really
good for because it puts you in direct
contests with other people who are at
your same physical level and so it
really pushes you and makes you grow and
that's interesting and i think like when
people think of like challenges and
stuff that's what they think about but
as you start to get older you know i'm
not getting in bar fights anymore um you
know like the last uh fight i was in
which was the first fight i had been in
unconstructed fight in a long time was
recently when uh one of my students was
attacked at the park right and i had to
uh step in and and handle the situation
and that was a self-defense situation
where the police were immediately called
i held the guy down until the police
arrived and i was more than happy to let
him go and i didn't want to prove that i
was the best i just didn't want him to
stab me or shoot me or hurt any of my
students that's what i didn't want to
happen you know and so your mentality
changes i think as as as time goes on
yeah yeah that's a great point i i agree
okay let me see
can i go back to
the list
irimi nage and i just kind of switched
it up you know i started ikea niko
sankyo but i thought
i thought let's mix in some stuff in
between the the good old six so you mean
i get
um my thoughts
entering inferring someone i think
that's
possible i think it's difficult to pull
off if i'm thinking about combat sports
uh very difficult because people are
always kind of being safe about their
distance and very very careful
if it's a random dude who doesn't know
what's happening i presume that it's
much more likely to enter
the fro itself i was done just like by
holding the back and going by the neck
i'm so much skeptical about it i've
found like there's the wrestling knee
tap which looks quite urinary-like um
and i think just modifying it somewhat
like using the hips more i was shown
that that worked really well i think it
can work pretty well uh
one of my concerns to some degree with
pretty much every aikido fro would be
if i throw someone if i'm attacked in
the streets and i throw someone and they
hit their head because they don't know
how to fall
that's kind of
dangerous in regards to the aftermath
maybe i can you know get into legal
trouble it depends but that's that's
kind of on my mind and okay how do i fro
and be conscious that i don't kill
someone and and even i kind of slams the
person down into concrete
um so yeah there's there's a bit of that
hesitancy there but obviously it's it's
survival you know it's it's a long story
self-defense is an endless subject but
those are the thoughts which are going
for my mind but in terms of making it
functional
just kind of working it making it work
in in various conditions
i think it has a pretty decent
shot but again as i said the entry is
puzzling still for me
but i guess let's say i'd say a b but
let's say a
let's be positive
okay so again it depends on kind of what
we're talking about um if we're talking
about sport martial arts i would put it
significantly lower um in no time in
mixed martial arts um did i ever pull
off an idi minage in live uh sparring it
comes off um from time to time but
usually heavily modified as as how we
see it in aikido um i think in the
aikido forms the way it's being shown
it's being shown in a way that's like a
special kind of situation that if it
came off it would it would it would work
really great but for most of the time
when you're talking about sport martial
arts you're not going to see that
situation arise that often it just
doesn't appear like i said i i've never
pulled it off um in that situation i
have pulled it off with weapons in a
couple different situations working with
my guys but it it just never had a lot
of functionality for me um now for as
far as we break down the principle to me
the principle of eating menage and the
way i talk about idiom is
a throw that happens from the rear
position so once you get behind someone
how do you throw someone and i call any
kind of throw that happens from that
position and eating
and i think that's highly functional
like trying to get behind someone in and
it's surprisingly easy if people aren't
trained you know so you work with
someone who's done some judo or some
boxing or something it's pretty hard to
get behind them but you know brand new
people i can slide behind them quite
often and then there's a myriad of
throws that can happen from that so um
so you know if you're talking about the
functionality of throwing when you're
behind someone it's highly highly
functional and a good thing to have but
as far as practicality is the way we
really see it regularly in aikido it's
not been very functional for me so you
know if i was judging my sport martial
arts experience and edie minage i would
say you know it's maybe a d or an e
because i i just i didn't i didn't get
it you know um as far as like
where it goes um like what the potential
is i would put it you know it's very
high so so it's kind of a similar answer
i'm giving you uh consistently which is
the idea of eating me nuggets we look at
it in a general sense is really good but
um it's hard the way we show the forms
it's very hard to get that to come off
so let's see i know this is tricky this
is very uh subjective it depends
relative uh but let's say the average
where would you average the technique
i put it a c or a b
okay
so
let's let's say final decision crb
uh let's leave it at c okay good nice it
looks better that way too
okay so
i guess i'll i'll try to throw in a
curveball
and choose a technique now which i have
pretty big doubt
about and that's okay
uh okay
interesting i'll put it here so now um
okay i have my thoughts how if it would
be heavily modified like if we look at
like the underlying principles of it
especially the the moment where you know
snapping down the neck and maybe using
the arm to fro
maybe i could imagine it working but
that would be a lot about snapping the
neck
locking the arm somehow but if we're
thinking about
and that's the part which is confusing
for me with kaitenag is the whole going
under the armpit turning out doing this
big circle of an arm and getting the arm
up top like that whole approach just
seems
almost impossible i don't i don't know
what made people think that someone
could pull that off in a fight
uh
but if we modified heavily and skipped
the beginning and we'd look just at the
point where it's the hand is on the head
somehow locking the elbow maybe even not
throwing maybe just sitting with the
person down i could see that is if we
would still call it titan like i could
see that being
possible but but my doubts about
kaitanagi are are high so i'd say wow
that's funny d okay hit me
um so i find variations of kaitenage
fairly useful um and i would put it much
higher and i would put it higher as far
as sport martial arts go and i would put
it higher as far as self-defense goes um
because uh i think
when you got someone going low for a low
leg tackle especially if they're not
someone who's a trained wrestler and
they're doing a perfect shot where
they're keeping their back straight you
know when when you're doing a really
nice shot you're back straight and that
makes kaitenage just about impossible
right so that straight back it defends
against that but most people don't most
people dive with their head and
so when people are diving in at you head
first kaitenage appears kind of a lot
and
you can't think of it like so to me
again you have to separate the form from
what the technique itself is and to me
all the technique is is i'm keeping one
arm open to the side right and i'm
controlling the head and so if you look
at that off of any bad shot if i get the
back of neck control and i get one arm
out to the side and i can go that
direction that will come up a lot um and
i have students who come up with it
regularly you know so it happens fairly
often um i would put it much higher for
sport martial arts now i think if you
think of the forum where it's like
someone's holding your wrist and you
turn to the outside and you cut your
hand down and you catch the top of their
head and you extend their spine and so
it's tight and then when you move just a
little bit they fly through the air
that's not going to happen so what's
really interesting for me when regarding
what you said makes me reflect about my
quantum code
my aikido journey
is is something i already
considered that may be a
kind of a flaw in my approach to
exploring it
is that i usually do it with
i end up doing it with high level
combat sports guys
like my brazilian jiu jitsu black built
coach
you know jesse income the karate nerd
who's been doing
karate for the entire life like his
brother ufc fighter and i i go to these
people because i want the highest level
of advice from well you know the people
who have the most experience to explore
aikido together with them right
but at the same time when i test
these techniques with them they're not
the regular type of human being and and
you know to pull off against them like i
couldn't even pull off
most functional techniques which i know
are functional i i did them on many
people but i can't even pull off that
against them because they're so good
and and maybe that's that's not maybe
you know that's a clear
kind of a flaw in my approach that
should be like the last step i should go
to these people only after i'm like so
good at these techniques so so yeah
maybe that's why kaiten that's one of
the reasons why kaitenage
was so low for me
in the scoreboard and also too when you
mentioned that people tend to dive in
i'm thinking like yeah that makes sense
i can see that but it's just
yeah training with combat sports guys
all the time i think my my radar is
flawed in that regard i think an
important thing to to point out and i
this is an argument i've heard a lot and
it's good argument that well if you can
pull off those things against high-level
people then of course you'll be able to
pull off the stuff that works against
high-level people against low-level
people right but the only problem with
that idea is that a lot of times you can
kind of round corners with people who
don't know what they're doing that you
can't round with people who are really
good and though that rounding of corners
can make things come off faster and
better and so a lot of times if i'm just
trying to preserve myself i can take a
lot of quick chances with someone who um
doesn't know how to grapple that i could
never do with someone who knows how to
grapple right and so um there is an
importance i think if you're looking
about self-defense what is the average
person going to do most of the time and
you know that's not to say that you
shouldn't do some heavy stuff with guys
who are really good because you should
understand that game too but look i am
never going to in a self-defense
situation grapple a black belt in
brazilian jiu jitsu i i'm going to shoot
him from as far away as i possibly can
right so if he's attacking me i want to
be as far away from that guy as possible
um and so so it's like you know what is
the regular guy gonna do who maybe comes
up on me right and that that's what i'm
looking at most of the time right
and that makes a lot of sense so so
that's i think i think that that's
something i should start incorporating
more into my explorations
uh
well
just to end the the argument about
caitanya so what's what score would you
give like what's the average between
uh it's i mean i would definitely put it
up in the in the b ish category for sure
i mean even even if we're looking at
sport sport martial arts it's highly
functional and to me it's aikido's only
answer for low stuff and i think it
answers most of the common low attack
problems so it's it's a really good
technique nice okay i'm i'm glad you
said that it changed my mind i was very
skeptical about it
okay well the next one is actually a
pretty doubtful for me as well
but you keep surprising me and actually
convincing me so so we're looking at
yonkyo uh
and
the trouble i have with yonkyo
conceptually in my mind
is imagining okay it's two on one it's
better than than nothing but then to
manipulate the entire arm
through holding just
the
the forearm
that seems
not so likely but i'm i'm just i'm just
not sure maybe
i don't have that much to say about it i
maybe i'm missing something so
let's okay let's say my to to be fair to
my skepticism
i'd put it
at an e
so what about you okay well uh it kind
of depends again on what you're looking
at yonko if you're looking at specific
forms and what the form gets done um not
very likely especially if you're looking
at combat sports
not not not very functional
i look at yonkyo simply as a gripping
technique so yonkyo is a way to grab
someone and drive the the index knuckle
in to the bones in their arm right or it
can be their leg or their face and i
like to mess with my students and do all
kinds of different ways but
anytime i grab something if i can wrap
my hand around it i can jump to it okay
now that for me has been highly
functional in dealing with
bratty kids and um over-the-top drunk
people where i'm not gonna punch them
i'm not going to hit them i'm i'm
ideally not going to throw them or
anything but i want them to act right
and if i grab them and apply some yonkyo
they tend to go oh that hurts and you
give them a menacing look and and they
tend to de-escalate a little right so
i've used it a lot of situations with
like unruly children uh that like you
know people that i'm physically not
hyper threatened by um but it does need
to get de-escalated and it doesn't need
to get de-escalated in a way where i
threaten them outwardly or i punch them
or something like that but that i just
need to give them some encouragement to
to stop being aggressive right and so to
me yonko's really good in that kind of
capacity right i uh i was taking a
firearms class with a next delta force
guy and he does a lot of um uh exec
protect stuff now so he protects like
celebrities and stuff like that and he
was saying one of the most useful tools
in his arsenal
is a pin and i was like why and he's
like well because when i'm moving
through crowds of people if i've got
some guy who's kind of being a jerk and
keeps trying to get the attention of
whoever i'm protecting i stick the pin
in the ribs and it hurts and then i give
him a menacing look and maybe i maybe i
go towards a gun and he's like with a
little bit of pain and a menacing look
they quit escalating and that's all he
wants is to de-escalate them right so he
doesn't want to hit someone because then
that goes in the newspaper right
but if he pokes someone with a pin a
little bit now look if that guy really
wanted to hurt the celebrity that pin
would do nothing but if he's on the
fence at all and he realizes oh man this
is a 6'5 300 pound like athletic looking
dude i'm not gonna do well anyways like
that was more than enough to stop me and
so yonkyo to me is that kind of thing
where it's encouragement to de-escalate
so you're not going to win a fight with
yonko you're never going to tap a ufc
guy ever in your entire life you're
never going to do that with yankee
you're never going to bring someone down
with yonkyokus not significantly smaller
than you and they're an aggressive
person but anyone who's riding the fence
a little bit yonko is a really good
technique and can be applied so subtly
by just grabbing someone and applying a
little yonkyo and it's like oh i didn't
like that feeling and maybe it's going
to get worse so i think it's good in
that capacity
that's again really interesting because
i just realized what happened in my mind
when i was looking at yonkyo the way i
was taught yonkyo was a lot based on
what was called connection
and that's you know very difficult term
to use to be honest but but the idea was
it was connecting to the shoulder
through the forearm and the focus was
very much not on the
the pain
you know causing pain part which that's
why i just almost eluded my mind i kind
of forgot like that exists there and i
was thinking about the okay use the
forearm just bring the person down which
was my skeptical part now that you
reminded me of of the pain part and that
actually is there and that that's
actually that may be like the
the yonkyo that's like the essence of it
that makes much more sense so
that's interesting
so
i think i've had the same lesson oh yeah
i think i've had exactly the same lesson
you had with the connection um and uh
you know while that's an okay way to
think about it my thought on that was
always well why wouldn't you just use
ekyo then because ikyo is better at
connecting someone's center than the
yonkyo is you connect from a stronger
point so to me the essence of the yonkyo
is that grip that grip is what makes the
yonkyo yunkyo nice that's a great point
so coming back to the board of
maker uh
considering all of that where would you
would you where would you reestablish
young kyoto
if you're looking at sport martial arts
like if this list is about sport martial
it's an f for a situation i need to
de-escalate a little bit um it might be
a c or a b you know it's useful and i've
used it a few times um i've used it with
drunks who want to leave and drive their
car and that was a bad idea um so so
it's it's functional you know but it
depends on your situation you're not
going to win a fight with it you're not
going to you know you're not going to
prove to every kid on the school ground
that you're tough because you can yank
it to someone because it isn't going to
work you know
but i guess based on the potential of
usefulness
what would be your
final average score like what's the i
lost you again ah shoot let's see okay
so let's finish this one and then i'll
restart um a router i'll give it a serie
d
scary so let's see
let's see
you have so you final decision like
what's what's the
where if you have to choose yeah it's
clear it's so hard because it's like i
can see
i can see different contexts you know
and so like to me you know if you're
looking at self-defense like if we are
really looking at self-defense then i
would give it uh
a b probably a b actually because i i
think it's it's fairly useful i've used
it um but if we're looking at sport
martial arts it's an f so so it really
really really depends it's almost like
we need two lists one that's like self
defense and one that's like sport
martial arts um because
they're different animals you know like
i'm never going to yonkyo someone in a
grappling match and then go oh tap tap
that's it i'm done right it's never just
never gonna happen right
so i guess uh i realized now okay this
this this list could be made more
sophisticated it could be two different
lists but let's see if we still commit
to finishing off that that middle ground
let's give it a d and i think that'll
average everything out let's give it a
okay perfect cool start looking at
jujin again
but at the same time i can't say i'm too
skeptical i can imagine
my hands getting there again but that
question is always there like how do you
get to that point like what has to
happen if i'm thinking about trained
guys
oh that that's tough untreating people
who knows they're crazy and
unpredictable
maybe you know
the arms to get there maybe i don't know
um so it's it's hard to say part of me
skeptical part of me is hopeful
ah jiu jinage
i'll i'll play it safe and say d
what about you
um i might put it at a c um so giuji
nage as far as like um
getting in an unarmed situation is
highly unlikely um because people don't
cross themselves like that very often
and most people are strong enough to
resist you crossing them unless you're
really strong right so you could
probably get it regularly with children
right because they're just they're too
weak to stop you from doing whatever you
want um however in arm situations juju
will come up a ton and just for this
reason so imagine i was gonna stab you
with a knife and you're holding this
hand if i clear this hand and start to
stab you over here then you'll reach
across your body to grab the knife to
stop me from stabbing you on this side
and i get juju a lot right so anytime
you pull the knife across their body and
you're isolating one side they'll reach
across to stop you and when they reach
across to stop you it's fairly easy to
crush that other arm on top of it so uh
in arm grappling situations comes up
fairly often i would say you know say if
i roll you know three minute rounds with
like five or six of my guys i probably
get it once once a night you know um so
so it comes up it comes up uh because
that reaching across but that doesn't
happen in uh unarmed situations right an
unarmed situation i don't reach across
my body for anything right so
yeah that's never gonna happen that's
really interesting because i just
realized so so you also include in your
exploration in your mind
when you have a weapon
and and you're sparring because for me
it's like i never consider that because
you know it's like the martial arts guy
you're the one defending against weapon
i unless you know i'm i don't know i use
a stick like an improvised weapon
but like yeah that's interesting so i
guess to just just double check you do
do that you do like weapon
grappling sparring right oh yeah
absolutely yeah yeah right yeah if you
come visit you'll do some too it'll be
great
i'm looking forward to that day
uh so you mentioned the c um so do
shall we leave it there or yeah i'd
probably put it as c that's fine yeah
okay
uh okay so i won't try to throw kerbals
anymore let's look at what's next on the
list uh
uh so
one version to call it is rocky
right so same here same here i came from
the rokyo
teachings so
i guess
again
train people very hard but
well that's always probably not always
the case but but that's that is the case
uh untrained people i think i can
imagine like how maybe you can lock that
elbow there still that getting the
person low down low
and lifting that arm up now that could
be a tricky part but i can imagine
it working like i don't know police type
of situation police students for
enforcing whatever so again can't
say a lot of it didn't try it yet
but i imagine it could be product like
effective so let's say i'll try i'll try
c
uh what about you
um i think i think it's it's really uh
uh useful i think you could use it in
sport martial arts i mean it's not gonna
come up a ton because again there's not
the emphasis on arms in sport martial
arts that there is in armed martial arts
right so like in sport martial arts
isolating an arm most of the time unless
i've already controlled the body isn't
that great an idea right so like you
know if i'm controlling someone's body
isolating an arm so i can submit it is a
great idea but like
in an arm situation i have to isolate
their arms all the time because they
don't isolate their arm they're going to
switch to the other hand and they're
going to use the weapon in their other
hand so the second i catch an armed hand
i'm trying to isolate it and so that
that rokio comes up a ton like i find it
super useful it also used to come up for
me a lot when i was younger and i was
first learning aikido and i didn't
understand like you know the way i do
now i would try ikyos on my friends and
they didn't work and they would
straighten their arms and i would turn
it into rokyo and so i got it in a lot
of roughhousing when i first started
aikido so i know with untrained people
it can come off quite easily and in arm
situations it comes off kind of a lot
you know so so super functional it's
also a technique that you'll find across
all jiu jitsu styles in japan they all
have that technique because it's really
useful when you're talking about that
kind of context
so what would be your
score
um i i would probably put it at the at
the b category i mean i think it's i
think it's way up there
now i'm curious what what will fill the
a which is not
a good question
yeah and just quick uh reflection before
i go to the next one that is interesting
now as well to consider again the
the spectrum of your journey and the the
kind of how wide it is because you
you didn't only do hand-to-hand
grappling but you also did
weapon defense and you did weapon to
weapon grappling so so that seems again
your mind is looking at way more many
things than i yet came
about to so so that's very cool
okay so uh gokyo
um
i actually pulled it off the other day
during but that that was a white belt
we were rolling and it was funny because
i'm not looking for a wrist flex like
everyone who's doing who knows that i
did aikido they're expecting me to like
be like a wristlock master
and i don't just don't don't see that to
be the case
uh i pull off corrugation we'll still
get to that but korea she's there all
the time especially with people who are
not seeing it coming
uh
for the first few times you know but
i'll get i'll beat myself later about
that but
but otherwise i'm not looking for wrist
locks but i was rolling with a white
belt and he had this his hand positioned
just there on the ground like that and i
was like
for a moment i was i was in a good
position and i was looking i was like i
guess i could just put some pressure on
top of that elbow and he's probably
gonna tap and i did it and he tapped him
and he was like oh what's this technique
i was like
aikido
but i was i was joking i wasn't serious
i didn't think like this was really
accurate but it was funny because it
just lined up so so that's just a funny
story to reflect about that it happened
to me recently other than that
and if i'm looking if i'm thinking about
i guess we're also including that grab
which is kind of similar to nikki or
grab
locking the
the wrist to the person and then maybe
using that wrist on the ground putting
pressure on it i can see
that it could be happening somehow i
don't have like entire faith but again
i'll just put it on the middle let's say
see
what about you
um you know i pulled it off uh graham
gravy it's funny talking about ground
grappling you know when i started doing
uh brazilian jiu jitsu and submission
wrestling um i didn't do a lot of uh
wrist locks either like and you know i
had the same thing you would be like oh
you know this guy knows aikido so he's
going to twist your wrist i was way more
interested in learning how to control
the body um and and then after i learned
that through doing submission wrestling
uh uh i i realized that i could pull off
a lot more wrist locks and so some some
nights i come to class and i just want
to hunt them down and so it's fun it's
fun like can i tap everybody with wrist
lock tonight you know um but but that's
just fun you know it's not i don't i
don't think it's functional it's not not
a good way to go about things right um
i've got it a bunch of times a lot of
times you'll get it because they grab
your ghee and you can kind of pull their
arm into your chest right so they'll get
your key like trying to mess it maybe
set up a choke or something and if
you're if they're not paying attention
you can hook that elbow and pull it
right in and you'll get a goku but
usually um it's just it's so shocking
that they tap real quick and most people
who know what's coming on they can
usually fortify their wrist and then
kind of turn their way out of it before
you get much of it so it doesn't have
the kind of security that something like
enikio has because nico the way you lock
into it's tighter um and so you can get
them but usually they're shocking fast
reactions um it's a decent disarming
technique the problem is it doesn't have
as much functionality as something like
nico so um i would put it maybe right in
there with yonkyo or just a little bit
above yonkyo where it's like i can do it
sometimes and and stuff comes off but
it's not going to be a dominating
technique ever you know like i don't
think it is very dominant technique so i
guess we put it down to d
yeah c or c yeah yeah it's fine yeah
these five okay
uh koshinaga is the next one
and
that probably is like when i think about
hit on functionality besides the
corrugation which is actually going to
be next uh that gives a lot of ideas to
me like how that could be used again i i
think about if i throw the person down
on the ground
if that's a like a real self-defense
situation and i use the hips to throw
i'm always concerned okay is he not
gonna break his on concrete
uh so that that's a question there
but but yeah getting your hips in
throwing seems like a lot of judo to me
uh makes sense
i imagine that it could be a very
functional technique
um
so i guess i'll i'll i'll put it at a
and what about you
um
live a bunch of times and it's funny
because
aikido koshinaga is just any throw that
comes off the hip so i mean like you
know if you're looking in judo that
could be like an ogo shahanai ghosh
maybe even like an uchimada like you
know like so anything where they're
lined up on your hip and you throw them
we call that koshinage and so you know
you know from judo um and grappling
around that
throwing someone on your hip is a very
viable way to throw someone so that's
that's real deal stuff the way it
happens in aikido is generally because
they're running at you and you get low
enough that they pop over no now that's
whether they're running from like uh you
know from shomonucci so we're in a tight
position where we're up here and i
transition in and they're pushing in at
me and i get down low and let them come
over my hips um i've got it i i have a
video of me getting it years ago um but
it's not it it's not that functional in
my opinion and the reason it's not that
functional is because aikido doesn't
teach you all the clinch positions to
get into that to use it like a sport
martial art would so like the concept as
far as like goes throwing some with your
hip yes that's a good concept aikido
doesn't really teach you how to get
there to do it right most the time so
that's not very functional and the way
we see it done in aikido what aikido
does teach you to do with it that
situation doesn't arise all that often
it comes up but it's not not traumatic
so you know if i was judging it inside
the system of aikido i would say it's
probably like a a c technique maybe um
if i was judging in sport martial arts
because the lack of ability to get to
the right clinch position to set it up
you know and you know from doing this
the setup is everything right so because
it has a lack of how to set it up um i
would give it an an f you know i don't
think it's good at all because
they don't teach you how to set it up um
as far as like self-defense goes it's
probably like a d or something you know
because it's like
it's just doesn't that happen doesn't
happen very often so i would put it
pretty low um i would probably put it
like in the c or d category where you
know it comes up and it's nice to know
but you know if you want to compare it
to what you would get in hip tosses uh
from judo or or any other real grappling
system it's not comparable you know not
it's a great point then right after
actually i finished my thought and i
thought about
your
soon-to-be answer i also thought about
weapons
and again
i'm far far from anything like an expert
so i'm just kind of guessing but
that's a very close technique and to get
there and
to get
first of all to get in there may be
dangerous and to be there and if
somebody has a knife or something
i imagine that can be also uh dangerous
and tricky i mean yeah i can see the
dangers of just just getting in under
the person i don't know do you have any
thoughts about that aspect of the danger
of i mean if you were going to hip toss
someone with um
with a weapon then
the way we do koshinage is about the
right way to do it because we hold the
arms really clearly when we're setting
it up so that is kind of where it's
going to come up um but it's just you
know if we're dealing with the arms i
generally don't want them in that
position for me because it's not too
strong and so i'm not going to choose it
and so it's only going to happen when
they force that situation to come up and
in my experience they don't force that
situation all that often you know
so
having said all of that what's your
final question i guess score
um i'd put it at a
i'd put it
i always want to say a c or a d i'd put
it as c let's put it as c see okay okay
okay
so uh next one is my favorite one
koregeshi well it's favorite because
it's the only aikido technique which i'm
confident in using in combat sports
especially
grappling
it's just fun it's just fun to see
people's faces when i do that for the
first time so it gets a reaction out of
everyone so so that makes makes me feel
happy and as long as they don't get hurt
anyway uh yeah i mean in regards to
self-defense
i have some doubts i mean the whole
i mean definitely not catching the hands
mid-air as people are throwing them i
think that's that's already out of my
question of the question for me uh
getting it to position when
i would grab the arm there's even a
video actually published on my channel
of someone can't uh send a contribution
of the video as they're working as a
bouncer
the cctv footage i don't know if you saw
that video
uh it's it's this big guy and
the bouncer and he later learned he did
combat sports and everything but he also
has an aikido background and he does a
koryashi you know the tiny guy
is trying to do something i don't
remember the setup actually
but he gets the hand he froze him with
the corgis and he pretty much does like
a pretty much a full-on high fall and
just he just froze him around but you
know he's he's bigger much bigger yeah
yeah but that played an influence but
we're talking about like a bouncer type
of
uh
fighting situation so i mean like i can
see how
how it could work i see some dangers in
it as well but i i like karageshi so
this will be a biased score
but just for the fun of it i'll i'll put
it in at an s i don't think it deserves
to be there oh wow all right yeah thank
you know but it's just i love it
so
uh
so yeah i don't think that's the right
score but but you're you you change my
score all the time anyway so so what's
your take
um i think it's a good technique i think
when you're talking about disarm
technique it's it's the number one
disarming technique um you can look that
cross-culturally you can look it in
chinese martial arts filipino martial
arts um you know anything anything where
they're dealing with weapons european
martial arts you will see that because
it's just an easy and efficient and
quick way to get something out of
someone's hand people generally want to
keep their elbows down naturally people
generally want to keep their elbows down
and so that code of guys comes off
really nice from that elbow down
position um so i i think it's really
great for that as far as like um using
it in in sport martial arts uh you've
been much more successful with it than i
have i i haven't gotten it all that much
uh arm grappling i've got it a lot more
um because it just comes up you know and
it's it's it's one of those that will
come up every single night if you do arm
grappling because it's just so
functional um so i'd put it in the a
class um i really think it and nikki or
are really really important in the same
ways um as far as like you know any kind
of the forms you know you're not going
to catch someone's i i did a whole video
talking about how you're never going to
catch someone's hand out of the air and
code a guy [\h__\h] um and you know people
have sent me things be like i did it
once it's like well cool out of the you
know six million times it's been tried
one guy got it once or seven guys got it
or whatever you know i don't care if 500
guys got it it's just it's not that
functional overall you know so um but
but it's great for disarming uh super
good for uh self-defense kind of
situations in my opinion so i'd put it
at an a i think i think it's a really
good technique that is indispensable in
the aikido syllabus
nice okay we i won i wasn't that far
turns out but probably a would have been
my rightful
choice but i like it so
okay
next one shionage a
quick reflection from my end uh i did
catch it
once or
oh no actually that wasn't strong i got
to be honest i i'm i actually was
thinking about a sankyo pulling it off
in grappling when going under a full-on
shield yeah no it's too far i remember
that i never got it there
i'm doubtful about the whole
again enter under the armpit turn the
arm get it to the person but if if let's
say there's some sort of situation
to get it to the arm to the shoulder
pull the person in fro i imagine that
could happen
again there's a lot of guessing in my
mind
uh
but okay i'll put it a c i yes i end up
being honest ca a lot but
okay now now the truth moment the moment
of truth
if you're talking about sport martial
arts i would give it an f it it's i mean
it's just so difficult to to do um
shionage is highly situation dependent
um you know it's one that i really can't
hunt um you know so but by that i mean
like sometimes i come to class and i'm
rolling with the guys or something and i
want to hunt out techniques and i'm like
i'm going to see if i can make the
setups happen for this or this or this
shionage is really impossible because
it's so long to get the technique
completed because of the turn it's
really really hard to get completed now
that being said it comes off really
naturally off of if you're doing like a
an elbow bar off my shoulder right and
they're pulling their arm back it'll
come off fairly naturally and then the
setups where i don't have to turn it
comes up right so people's hands will be
high or whatever and you can kind of get
a hold of it it'll work for sport
martial arts it sucks you know like i
would give it an f um in self defense it
comes up fairly often because we're
struggling over the weapon and it's got
that little tiny area that we're
focusing on like this and so if i'm
turning to wrench the weapon free and
they're just trying to stay with me they
might give that to me and then i would
get the [\h__\h] so um it's not it's it's a
nice technique in the aikido syllabus i
see naturally why it arises and if you
look at it as a clearing technique and
not as a throwing technique which you
shouldn't because it's called nage um
but but if you look at it as a clearing
technique it's much more useful most of
the time when i go into a shionage
people just let go of me and that's how
it's useful to me not that they go for
the full ride and take a big fall or
anything um so
it's it's functional i would probably
put it c or d um i don't think c is bad
but um you know i would say for myself
how often it comes off is more in the d
category not super often okay so i guess
a d would be like more or less the final
one
looking at the whole
table uh okay now this one is i'm i'm
really curious uh what you're going to
say tenchnage
and
you know there's some similarities
between it and irimina i guess the whole
entering it's just you're not entering
on the outside i guess you're entering
more in the inside as far as i remember
it's been a little while since i tried
it uh but there's also if i'm looking at
the essential setup for tension i get
there's the holding of the arm
you know the person is holding you and
you're doing the cut down to unbalance
no
questions asked why the person is still
holding on to you
uh so that part is
puzzling and if i make it into an
integral part of tension again that
first that there is that cut
i mean that's the earth element
and then the top
that makes me very skeptical i don't
know how to make it functional if we're
just looking at the top part
or maybe holding i'm again i'm just
brainstorming think out loud but maybe
grabbing the arm pulling the person down
and then going up
maybe but i have a lot of doubts so
i'll guess i'll i'll go for an e just to
justify my doubts
but i'm really curious what's what's
your opinion about it
again if it's sport martial arts it's an
f you're you're never going to see it um
uh especially not in the the classic
form that's always shown which is from
ryote doria two-handed grab in arm
grappling it comes out because a lot of
times uh i'll have a knife someone will
someone will grab the hand i do a quick
switch and they grab the other hand so
you get real thing and then in that
flurry you drive one high and one low
and and they'll stay with you um so it
happens um
in aikido it's not super common um so i
would say you know in my aikido practice
it's like uh it comes off sometimes so
maybe a d or something
as far as sport martial arts go it's an
f because i've never got it and i don't
even see how i would get it um as far as
self-defense goes if it arises it's
useful but
it just doesn't arise
tragically tragically often now
hand grappling over something happens
fairly often right because any time uh
you know if you do any training with
with weapons you'll see that the second
you grab someone's hand the first thing
they want to do is put it in their other
hand and so that leads to a lot of
realtory situations right so you're
either going to go switch topic or
they're going to go
and so you see it all the time
and and so the principle of tinchinage
which is the high-low principle you're
talking about it works really well
because it splits their body and people
don't like that so they want to let go
of one and that puts you in a more
autonomous position so it's good for
that so the principle's great and
talking about it that way is is fine and
if you're talking about arm grappling
it's a good thing to talk about but for
sport martial arts it's an f and i would
say in the aikido
how often do i get it very very seldomly
so it's in the in the cd category you
know so um where did you put it at c
i i was an f because i sorry i wasn't an
e because i was very skeptical uh oh
yeah yeah i mean it's it's not that
functional you could leave it at e okay
no not nice that'll make it more uh
uniform your chart looks happier for you
right yeah exactly it looks better now
okay cool that's interesting
so
quick reflections it's every time it's
interesting how you do find those
principles because you know a lot of
people that's what they talk about
especially like people who want
to
to to kind of
shed good light on aikido
a lot of times the talk goes to aikido
is about principle it's it's not about
the techniques and i was kind of looking
into it and i have some of my ideas what
that could be but it seems you really uh
dove deep into that and you really like
uh clarified and kind of discovered
those principles
beyond the techniques uh so so that
that's really cool
okay so uh
next one is
i believe this is sumi otoshi
uh okay which
i i kind of deliberately put it in there
because
it also exists in judo
yeah
and
i guess again combat sports
if a person has a good base
i don't see that throw happening
with um
people who have no idea what's happening
maybe
[Music]
but i'm not that sure i i mean again i i
wish i tried it in judo because you know
judo they have to make it work because
they're so competitive and and there's
so much resistance there
so
but i'm not not entirely sure let's say
i'll put it on a d and just look forward
to your opinion
yeah i mean uh you know uh i have a
student who that's his bread and butter
and he loves it and uh uh he'll do it
all the time um and so uh you know i
know for some people that works out
really well my game if you look at sport
martial arts never was about that my
game was always about core control so
you know if i'm taking someone down i
want to get a hold of your body or your
legs that's what i want um and so like i
i really very seldomly mess with arms
with the exception of maybe like a
shionage or sorry a sayonagi or
something um and that's just because i'm
going from an arm to get the body behind
me um so so for me i really never got it
a whole lot i get it sometimes when
we're messing around um uh and i see the
functionality of why it can come up
especially in an arm situation in an um
situation not as much but like you said
it's in judo um i would like to see what
the um you know the competition results
are of it i bet it's fairly low
percentage compared to something like
you know sayonage or or ogos or
something you know uchimata is probably
like way up there but but you know it is
possible you can do it in its old core
old-school stuff and i think why it's
still in judo is because it comes from
armed stuff and it's more likely to come
out in an armed situation in my
experience it looks a lot more muddled
than it usually looks in aikido it's
it's much more ugly technique and it
looks much more like some kind of rear
tripping technique or something you know
um so what about your score how would
you uh i don't know i'd put it in the
maybe c it's a c
okay see
nice two similar pictures next to each
other
uh and with the kimi nagi uh so that one
for me
uh you see the the picture there
yeah i don't think i i can't see what it
is what you call it
i guess so so essentially
imagine somebody is giving if we're
thinking in in back in our aikido days
somebody is doing at ski i step out of
the way i grab the arm i turn next to
that person so i'm holding the arm
extended arm i'm next to that person i
put my hand under their extended elbow
and i
lower the extended arm put pressure on
the elbow and turn my arm to throw that
person um
yeah okay got it okay good i'm happy the
the my
explanation
worked out and
made the connections so so yeah i was
introduced to it as in the kimi nagi
uh and
yeah again i can see some ideas how that
could work as always the question is how
you get there maybe
uh two on one
arm drag
get in there maybe extending the arm
could be hard but yeah i think i can see
the the potential behind it in my mind
so i almost want to go like a ba
but but that's all guessing land for me
so so now for the truth
for for sport martial arts you know it's
it's high up there i mean it's it's like
a russian two-on-one um so i mean
there's there's a ton of stuff you can
do from that you can go into fireman's
from that you can go to so if you're
looking at unarmed stuff it's totally
way up there it's just two arms on one
held holding it tight um the way we
specifically do it is functional but you
probably won't see it resting much
because it is against the joint right
like obviously against the joint um i
think you know very functional for mixed
martial arts very functional for um any
kind of stand-up grappling stuff and
highly functional and a self-defense
situation um in aikido itself it comes
up fairly often so you know it's
probably a a b probably a b somewhere in
there yeah okay finally something we
agree on obviously i'm just guessing
but okay b b works got it
and now
aiki otoshi you know if you don't just
in case you don't see the picture it's a
guy because it's cut out it's a guy
grabbing the legs and throwing i was
familiar with the version where there's
no grabbing of the legs
you just step behind the legs and use
the arm to fro kind of tripping them
um
but uh but still
that's the picture i found online
so
yeah i can see that happening totally
like tripping the person again the entry
is always the question how you get there
uh
but and also to actually
quick quick fun story when i went to
thailand recently and did some waitai
at a thai gym mai tai gym uh i did
specifically remember aikidoshi and i
asked the coach i said hey i think
there's like a familiar similar
uh f
throw in in white i saw something online
and we looked at it and yeah it was
similar enough it's it's much more fast
and
uh a bit more snappy than
really getting yourself in there and
doing that throw but yeah i think i can
see that working so i guess because of
my positive spirits i'll go for an a
but what what's the truth
uh well i mean so for uh
sport martial arts it's high up there um
tim carmel has a whole series uh working
on basically this idea he has an ankle
pick in there and you know a whole
series that works on it's really nice
the beautiful series um it exists in a
bunch of kung fu styles sua xiao has it
uh i think judo has it um so it's common
so yeah for unarmed stuff you're gonna
see it a lot and like from where you're
looking at it mostly i would say uh
putting it up there is pretty good um
for me and what i'm looking at for
self-defense it's not really that great
because it leaves the arms unchecked uh
and i'm in a low position with unchecked
arms and so if they have a gun or a
knife i'm dying you know like so it's
it's it's dangerous to to temporarily um
and uh you know so we have the same name
um that uh ikea tosh but it but it
doesn't look like that it really just
depends more upon them like rushing at
you uh in some way but um as far as that
version goes for under sport martial
arts it's great i think it's really good
i think you can see that repeated in
many different styles um for self
defense it's not very good uh i so
personally the way i look at martial
arts i would put it pretty low um it's d
maybe because it's functional but it's
dangerous
very good point yeah
and uh actually so this is the last one
because the next one is it just again
yeah i just stick here again it's like
oh he killed it just put it then
yeah there we go
so the cokin this is a picture of
kokinage and i was kind of thinking
about whether to put it there or not at
all because kokinagi is
it's kind of a general term i guess
there's so many different variations of
kokinage
but but all those
nice big throws from aikido
uh
i don't know dude would would you have
like a specific place here on the tier
list
for kokunage or you think it's just too
obscure of what it is specifically
when we're talking about principles like
you know uh it is as principle as esque
as they come if you look at psychosense
he calls probably about 12 different
throws kokinagi's right um so it's it's
really hard to say no it's a principle
and so like like tinchinage as a
principle of splitting the body into
tinchinagi's good as it comes off it's
not good and kokenagi is real hard to to
come into because what does it mean now
i in my school have one specific thing
that i call a cookie nugget but that
doesn't match up because all aikido
schools use it in different ways so you
know a kokinagi is a throw that should
come off with natural ease and so i
think that's a great way to think about
doing throws but technically what does
that mean i don't know so i don't i
don't even know where i'd put it on the
list i mean you know
a well done throw is it isn't is a s up
there for super but also like you know a
principle that you don't really can't
get your hands on especially for a new
person it's an f so
so yeah it's a hard it's a hard one to
get in true so it's a good point whether
i was i was wondering whether i should
put it there as well but i i just was
interested about the discussion of it so
and i think you just answered my my
question so uh
before i start summarizing what what we
see
um
is there any technique and you know
there are those
various variations of aikido techniques
but in regards to those popular
techniques
which most aikido schools practice is
there anything that uh you would have
put
that i missed out on
um probably not i mean so you know i i
have a set of um uh hinko nage which
means variation throws um so like
sayonage i teach a sayonage and i think
it has a place in regular aikido um and
i think cyanide is fantastic but it's
not seen in all aikido style so
i could see not putting it in there um
uh yeah i mean this is pretty
representative of i think a lot of
aikido schools um
yeah i i think it's pretty yeah because
you have all the kyowasa essentially um
and i think you have all the nagewaza so
kokinagi koshinagi kaitanage
yeah so yeah i mean i think this is this
is core aikido pretty solid there's one
technique uh just for the interest of
discussion uh
there's this thing where some aikido
schools do you know the no
sorry
no ski no i guess so because i i was
never in a school which would teach that
i would only see it online
that looks pretty functional but again i
guess just because
i never
bumped into it through visiting a third
hand a handful of schools i i presume
it's not like a super popular like not
like the
bread and butter of aikido schools i
think you've seen a lot of tin
um right i i don't see it in a lot of
other other schools um yeah sure it's
functional putting your hand in
someone's face and pushing their head up
that's that's a functional thing you can
use that but but you agree that it's not
like the the usual no it you know it's
not um you're not going to see it in a
whole bunch of aikido styles right and i
guess it also kind of goes a little bit
against
the
spirit of osensei who's who's all about
how do we make these techniques more
aesthetic more more peaceful more
more kind of less less violent and that
direct
i guess
i mean i would argue that that is way
less violent than cutting a guy with a
sword and yet we can find tons of videos
of him practicing cutting people with
swords so right uh you know it all
depends on it's all situational you know
and so so i do believe aikido is a
peaceful martial art in that it's
looking for the best resolution possible
but the best reasons possible might be
pushing someone's chin so i can get out
of there you know so so it all depends
on on where you're at yeah yeah the
total question i don't want to
expand too far into this because this
could be a whole different subject but
but that question was always puzzling
for me like okay aikido is all about the
art of peace but why the hell are we
cutting each other with sword and
stabbing each other in
like the ribs and etc it's like that and
also to like throwing somebody with a
shihanagian concrete where's the piece
in that so
that's a bit of a
complicated question i think
right
yeah i mean i think uh i think just real
quick on it i mean i think if we just
have a shift in what i'm thinking about
doing am i thinking about dominating the
other person or am i thinking about
making a peaceful environment in the end
right now how we get there
could involve all kinds of things but if
my goal is just to beat someone up you
know if someone says hey i don't i don't
want to be here anymore i'm sorry i
messed with you and you run after him
and cut him down with your sword that's
very different than six guys came into
my house and tried to attack my family
and i had to cut them with swords it's a
different situation right
yeah true
so looking at
what we see here uh what comes up to
your mind like how how does this look is
this how it looks like you expected i i
realized and wanna
uh say that on record that that you know
there's these as you said like these
could be two different lists self
defense combat sports but if we're
looking at the average
potential of keto techniques to be
functional or keto principles behind the
techniques uh is this first of all is
this what you were more or less
expecting to see
yeah i mean i i don't know i mean
i i'm not trying to be a bummer here but
like it's really hard for me to see past
the contextual arguments right and so
like you know if if we were looking just
at sport martial arts this should
probably all be significantly lower um
but when you you asked me about it it
was like oh let's talk about it for
self-defense and different things so and
it's like for self-defense a fair amount
of these might need to be higher for
armed grappling which is somewhere kind
of in between those ideas a lot of these
ideas would be higher you know so it
really kind of depends on on the context
that you're looking at it um you know
for sport martial arts i gave a bunch of
these things f's i was like well i just
i just don't think that's useful at all
and that was my experience doing sport
martial arts and that's why the first
two years of doing sport martial arts i
was like aikido doesn't work most these
techniques are apps but when i start to
understand
different contexts then it's like oh
well with another context this actually
makes a lot of sense whereas something
like you know a double leg takedown and
a self-defense situation in my opinion
is an f and you might say well you're
going to be successful in taking them
down yeah but getting stabbed and
getting hurt and putting yourself in a
bad position that's all highly likely to
so you know it really depends on the
context you're looking at things right
since you mentioned that would you be
okay with playing this quick let's call
game and uh just
naming
if we do what exactly what you said like
we'd go for combat sports
and then self defense and you just name
letters like i tell you names and you
just name letters with
would you be up for it
sure i'll play any game you want but
what what exactly are the rules of this
game yeah okay so so let's say we start
with combat sports
and i say without too much elaborating
just i'm curious to see how it will lay
out okay okay gotcha you're going to
point to the technique and then i'll say
combat sports what yeah yeah so let's we
start with ikio combat sports what rank
would you give
uh e
okay e
uh
actually
i don't want to make this
okay well it may be actually fun to move
around hopefully i won't forget what we
already said so nico
uh
d
e e for support martial arts
uh e sports martial arts yeah
uh
thank you
[Music]
with the kimi nagi you know the one i
just had uh
uh a b or an a yeah b a okay
uh
now i'm trying to get confused did i did
i ask you for a question
huh okay uh you mean that again uh
e f f
oh for me personally
yeah uh juju nagy
uh f
um
question again
uh
maybe a d i don't know it's not it's not
my technique so okay so let's see
yeah okay d because i know i know it
gets used in other things
uh yonkyo
f
i like that
uh
e
hmm
i think that's it
right we went yeah i think that's uh
yeah i think we got them all yeah okay
um so that's what i would that's exactly
what i would expect in sport martial
arts you know like it's just those
techniques are not very useful for it so
okay so
combat sports and and that's where a
reflection suddenly comes to me
is
maybe that's that's how i kind of saw
i i have to admit like i do investigate
and put a lot of thought into like what
cell defense is but usually when i
really care about self defense i go into
avoidance you know just deterrence the
the whole aspect of noticing conflict
before it happens avoiding the wrong
places and then obviously having some
skills with where combat sports would
likely be useful
but i don't think about techniques as
much when i think about cell defense and
so when i think about aikido i think my
mind was probably always more like okay
so how does this work in jiu jitsu how
does this work in boxing and et cetera
and and you had you said this great
thought
that it is to some degree a valid
uh viable
thought process because if i can use
this on a high level guy
then it means it's legit
but but that's also flawed because i
wasn't considering
random untrained people uh and i wasn't
considering so much about
aikido in relationship to
weapons
and
street occurrences so so that's probably
how
aikido looks like more or less besides
did you put it karigashi at a d
yeah i did that for you i would have put
it lower personally okay i appreciate it
so so i would just put korean but aside
from that
yeah i that's probably how
my
tier list would look initially more or
less
or at least that's where i come from now
i'm starting to shift having
conversations like these
so that's that's my thank you any any
thoughts for you to add about this
before we move on to self defense
yeah no i mean i think this is a good
thing to look at because i think most
people without even understanding it
they're asking about one context which
is basically the context that's answered
by sport martial arts and that's why a
guy like joe rogan's like you know joe
rogan had made some comment not too long
ago that was like you know oh we've made
more advances in martial arts in the
last 20 years than we had in the last
2000 and i was like joe do you realize
we invented the chariot in that time we
invented ballista in that time when you
know like he's not thinking contextually
and i think most people are doing that
where they're thinking oh martial arts
are about a one-on-one fight where i
prove to someone that i'm a tough guy
and for some people that is all that
martial arts is and there's nothing
wrong with it because that was
definitely me at one point in my life um
but then there's other contexts to
consider as well right so you know if if
we were going to go fight in a
battlefield somewhere um we're not going
to run out there and do jiu jitsu like
it's almost useless to us you know um
and so like it depends on the context
you're in and so for for sport martial
arts aikido is not very good and so when
people say aikido sucks it's like well
it's because you're talking about sports
stuff and and that
there there are all kinds of other
problems that come into that but like
the techniques are not built for sport
and so they don't work for that and
they're not particularly great for that
but i think a lot of sport techniques
aren't very great for self-defense so
true yeah it's a great point that
i noticed that happening early on in my
beginning journey of questioning martial
arts and i think that's even evident in
some of the first videos i made
exploring martial arts like one of them
was why aikido lost popularity one of
the first videos that went big that
you know kind of went out there
the first time i made it and i was
addressing that point that we are
looking at we we're not exactly setting
up
the conversation like what are we
talking about exactly it's it's very
often it's vague it's like does it work
and and you're very good at catching
that it's like does it work for what
uh but most people are like yeah they
have some idea but maybe we have
completely two ideas of what means to
work and we're having a discussion
imagining we're talking about the same
thing but we're not and
it's really confusing
so regarding
self-defense uh sorry just turn off the
sound that does not disturb okay so if
we good if we go through the same
quantum code game
for self defense
i'll start from the
top
so
i keep forgetting the name you used so
i'll say it with the kingdom
[\h__\h]
um so
it's probably solid at a b it it's it's
pretty pretty functional okay uh aikidos
uh an e
um
um a b probably
okay
um
a b probably a b yeah
mm-hmm
um a b
uh maybe an a an a actually i i i
there's a lot of functionality in kodak
nice
uh samiatosh
um
[Music]
probably a c
and and that's probably i'm probably
being picky because i don't get it a lot
personally but
i know for some people it comes off a
lot right uh ikyotosh
uh we already got that one i think oh
sorry yes thank you thank you
uh
a
c a c
[Music]
mm-hmm
an a
we'll put it at a d because i know
you're not gonna like that empty column
so i was going to say c or d so
okay i i appreciate you making it
visually nicer
uh
um a d
it's funny so yeah like you can do
another one of these i don't want to do
a million but like we could definitely
do another one we talked about
conceptually whether that's a good idea
or not um versus like how pragmatic is
it to get to there because i think
eating me nuggets probably an s as far
as conceptually goes but it's not easy
to do on the regular so um so yeah
probably a d
i guess also
i imagine this would be different if we
would be
weapon defense hand to hand
when i'm when i'm thinking of uh
self-defense i'm thinking of situations
that always include weapons and multiple
attackers and so it's like that's how
i'm looking at all these right now okay
so that's included in your mind got it
thanks
and did we
forgive me for forgetting did we go for
jiu-ji naga already i don't think uh no
we didn't i'd put it probably at a d or
c
hm
let's say final call uh c or d
c
okay
a d probably i don't get it as often as
i'd like
okay
there we go
so uh what comes to your mind hey we got
a bell curve there yeah nice it looks
very nice it's like that's how aikido
was supposed to look like
so what comes to your mind when you look
at this picture
yeah this is this seems about right um
because you know like uh uh ekyo is
first principle for a reason and it's
because i think it has a ton of
functionality to it you can use it in
lots and lots of ways and conceptually
so it's one of the techniques that the
technique itself is good and the concept
is good and so it's like it all kinds
comes together in the in the just right
thing um and to me nico and koregash are
indispensable if you're talking about
any kind of weapon taking if you're
talking about self-defense situations
you're either going to be keeping
someone from taking your weapon or
taking someone else's weapon and so
pretty pretty highly functional stuff um
and uh yeah it seems to fall out and
about the way it should you know nice
and i i think it's it's almost important
at least when i think about my audience
i think it's important to mention that
and and do correct me if i'm wrong
that
this applies to training aikido in the
right way because i think that that's
one of the troubles with aikido is the
methodology the way it's trained
is
usually not
great and i'm obviously not talking
about your school uh but i think when we
speak if somebody would jump in here in
in this conversation right here right
now
and they would think about the aikido
they did
and they would look at this list and and
let's say they became conscious of the
flaws behind it and they would think
about their training methodology they'd
be like
no everything is an f you know like i
was and maybe you were as well one day i
don't know
right but i guess but so so would you
agree that this is this applies
to
aikido which is trained with pressure
testing and
at least as i understand it yeah i think
that's right and i mean i think you know
so i could probably do a
a rating on these two as to like
what self reflectively aikido thinks you
know so for example self reflectively
aikido thinks we would put um idi minage
right up there at s we'd put kokukunage
on the board and we'd put that at s also
because like those are such core
techniques to the learning of aikido and
i think a lot of principles are learned
through that but that doesn't
necessarily mean the technique is
something that either comes off often or
easily and and often and easily if i'm
talking about saving myself is something
that i'm really considering how often
does it come off and how easily does it
come off because that's what i want
techniques that are often an easy